ABC announced something happen the new
cast of Dancing with the Stars I haven't
done anything to challenge myself in
decades right in the boat a conic gold
medal Olympian Mary Lou Retton dukes of
hazzard John Schneider and the facts of
life's Nancy McKeon round out the triple
threat of 80s nostalgia I actually
thought of the most terrifying thing in
the world to do for myself and then said
yes
retired Broncos Super Bowl champ
DeMarcus Ware is this season's pro
athlete and singer Tinashe represents
the pop stars as for the remaining
contestants the pros will be dancing
with the supporting stars I deal in
produce for one thing I haven't produced
yet Islam and grocery store jobs claim
to fame is being kicked off by Becca on
the first night of The Bachelorette
I mean he's grocery store Joe and
there's Evanna Lynch who's best known
for playing Harry Potter's Hogwarts
schoolmate Luna Lovegood why no showing
he pays to turn up and dance for weeks
on end yep this was a no brainer in
years past fuller house stars Candace
Cameron Bure and Jodie Sweetin took on
the ballroom next season it's Juan Pablo
de poche a who plays Kimmy gibbler's
love interest
they just said loved every minute of it
it's gonna be intense the process and
trust Herald 21 seasons
[Music]